Thank you very much!
[Music]
[Applause]
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa This is the
last student. I'm sorry for the
inconvenience.Thanks to you, I
was able to talk to many students.However,
I still don't think that interspecies exchange is the right thing to do.
Do you all need me like this?
What are you talking about now?
What do you mean? Who is the one who
deals with so many beasts one by one and
has the best interaction with other races?
Interspecies exchange: I
like this feeling of wanting to be of help to everyone. It
was an exchange that belonged to me. I
felt like I was being left behind by everyone who was changing day by day, but
I was like, oh, he goo,
he
goo.
[Music]
me
aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa lookaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa ways,
I've got something like this ” AAaaAAAaaaAaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa haven
11A's
No, it's too early for
people to take off their clothes.If you want to take off your clothes, you
can take them off.Well, I'll take your
word for it,
but if possible, I'd like to ask you to do that.
[Music]  Is
this okay? Hey, this
is a great way to keep things in check. cf. I'm a thief when it comes to naked mole rats.
Cheer
[Music] It's
easier to manage this way.